Speaker 1: So last week, we had a big discussion
across multiple days about should progressives
just now at this point work to kill the spending
and infrastructure bill that's been completely
gutted.
I gave you a list last week of five six major
pieces of the proposals that had been floating
around that are believed to be completely
dead in the water.
And I said, at this point, I'm OK with progressive
saying, kill it.
I often say if it does some good, then it
should be supported it because it's a step
in the right direction.
It will help some people in any opportunity
to help people should be taken.
I started to go in the direction last week
of there's so little here that this will serve
as a victory for centrist Democrats by saying
we don't have to do anything progressives
want.
It will serve as a victory for Republicans
for saying the more we obstruct, the less
they're going to get, even if we're not in
control.
And it's nothing for progressives.
We've got a voicemail related to killing the
bill, which I'm going to play for you in a
little bit.
One bit of news is that Bernie Sanders is
not giving up.
Senator Bernie Sanders appeared on CNN yesterday
and made it very clear that he's still pushing,
at least to get lower drug prices into the
bill.
Now, if he was able to do that, is lower drug
prices, price controls on on medications and
prescriptions.
Would that be enough to to say, well, OK,
just for that alone, progressives should support
it.
We'll get to that in a second.
Let's first listen to some of this interview
he gave.
Speaker 5: You have said there are major gaps
in this plan.
Several of your priorities paid leave, dental
and vision for Medicare, giving the government
power to negotiate lower prescription drug
prices for seniors.
That's not in the deal.
You saw that House Progressive endorsed Doris
the compromise, do you?
Speaker 6: Well, it's not in the bill yet,
but what I can tell you, Donna, we are working
right now.
We spent all of yesterday on the telephone.
We are paying the highest prices in the world
for prescription drugs.
Are the pharmaceutical industry has spent
hundreds and hundreds of billions of dollars
to make certain that Americans pay ten times
more for some drugs than the Canadians or
the Mexicans do.
That fight continues, and the fight to expand
Medicare look poll after poll shows that the
American people understand it is not acceptable
that elderly people have teeth in their mouth
that are rotting.
They can't digest their food.
They can't, they don't have the vision that
they need in order to read a newspaper.
So we are continuing that effort.
So can I just pains me very much?
Speaker 5: I'm sorry.
Go ahead.
No, I just want to just make sure that I understand
what you're saying.
You're saying you're continuing that effort.
You want to still add it before the House
votes.
You want to add it to the bill that absolutely.
Speaker 6: Look, we're working as everybody
should know on two separate bills.
You've got a bipartisan infrastructure bill
which will finally begin to address the reality
that our roads and our bridges and our water
systems are crumbling.
That's one bill, but we want to move both
bills in tandem.
And the second bill, the bill that deals with
the needs of the working class of this country
in terms of child care, in terms of pre-K
that deals with the existential threat of
climate, that bill is still being worked on
literally today.
It will be worked on tomorrow.
I believe we're making some progress in making
an even stronger than it is.
Speaker 5: If it if you don't succeed in that
progress, will you support the framework as
it currently stated?
Question what the White House released at
the end of the week.
Speaker 6: Well, all I will tell you is we
have a very, very strong bill and it deals
with the fact that we are going to start paying
attention to the needs of working parents.
Continue that $300.
We're going to build affordable housing.
We're going to make sure that elderly people
and people with disabilities can stay at home
rather than be forced.
Speaker 1: So Bernie goes in to talk, you
know, these are these are talking points that
we've heard before.
But so the fundamental question ultimately
gets to, let's say, Bernie and other Democrats
get lower prescription drug price provisions
into the bill.
Then should progressives support it?
In my mind, that actually would be enough
to say support the bill, and it wouldn't change
the fact that it would still be missing and
lacking so many things that were talked about
early attacks that target, you know, between
these two bills tax that targets the very,
very richest billionaires, paid leave, child
care, you know, so Medicare expansion, so
many things that I am in favor of and that
are good and that are necessary and that should
be in there.
All of those things would still be gone, but
the degree to which the American people are
getting screwed when it comes to prescription
drug costs and it's so popular to talk about
lowering prescription drug costs, both Democrats
and Republicans talk about it all the time.
Trump talked about it.
He didn't do it.
But the mechanisms through which they would
do it, of course, differ.
There's no question about that.
It actually would be so materially useful
to so many people, particularly seniors, the
way that Bernie Sanders is talking about because
of how Medicare works.
That again, I'm talking pragmatically.
I know the optics are terrible, but that is
so good for so many people that I would probably
say, don't kill the bill, get the bill done.
If that's in there now, how likely that is
to happen and how much of this is Bernie either
posturing or trying to put public pressure
on colleagues.
And we just don't know.
We just these negotiations are happening constantly
between different parties, and this is why
my coverage of this has basically been listen,
the entire process is a grandstanding quagmire.
There's a lot of this that is just the worst
of politics and worst of the D.C. Beltway.
It doesn't relate to people who are just trying
to afford gas, trying to afford food, trying
to afford medication.
It just doesn't connect.
It's so abstract and and idealized in some
way by those who think, Oh, big, negotiate.
It's it's a lot of B.S. that's going on, and
I get all of that.
But if there's really going to be something
actually done and if you trust Bernie, if
you're a Bernie supporter, if you believe
Bernie does the right things or tries to,
then you would imagine that if he gets that
into the bill, it's going to be materially
substantive.
I think I'm probably back on and say, just
just pass it and get it done, and then let's
move on and try to do more and do the next
iteration.
If you disagree with me on the value of prescription
drug price controls as reason alone to support
the bill, I want to hear from you.
Reasonable people can disagree, but it seems
like an important thing to me.